sie rennt als kleine heldin durch eine
bunte spielewelt stundenlang
hochkonzentriert aber ohne erkennbare
freude
mia ist 9
meist ist sie allein und eingesperrt
seit über einem jahr den größten kinder
gefängnis der welt
unten auf der schwelle sitzt ihre mutter
und achtet darauf dass sie das haus
nicht verlässt
wer vor die tür geht den hole die
polizei und meine mutter hat nicht genug
geld um mich wieder auszulösen
genug geld hat keiner der hier wohnen
muss im flickenteppich aus
wellblechdächern kann zwischen
schnellstraße und containerhafen am rand
von manila tagelöhner müllsammler
hilfsarbeiter und ihre familien das
leben im slum happyland war nie einfach
aber nun ist auch das elendsviertel
sowie das ganze land im lockdown im
längsten und härtesten locker und der
welt seit über einem jahr dürfen kinder
wie mia nicht vor die tür zum spielen
oder in die mauer
sie müssen masken tragen wenn sie das
nicht tun und erwischt werden droht den
eltern eine strafe viele gehen trotzdem
raus zum spielen auch ohne maske aber
ungefährlich ist das nicht
in den sozialen netzwerken findet man
solche fotos sie sollen kinder zeigen
die nach corona verstößen den hunde
käfigen eingesperrt wurden
die philippinen bekämpfen das virus mit
militär und polizei als sei es ein
bewaffneter feind für seine kritiker hat
präsident dotierte ein berüchtigter
autokrat nur zynischen spotten
manche sagen immer noch wir würden nicht
genug tun was dennoch wir haben
krankenhäuser betten und
bestattungsinstitute es fehlt doch
nichts
den wächtern an den straßensperren gab
er die erlaubnis aufmüpfige notfalls zu
erschießen millionen kindern die wie die
kleine mia eingesperrt sind empfahl er
nun eben viel fern zu sehen
denn die schulen sind seit über einem
jahr geschlossen und nun auch noch die
armenküchen in dieser auch mit deutschen
geldern unterstützten einrichtung werden
lunchboxen aus reis und frittierten
fisch besten zubereitet und verteilt
eine box für ein kind an einem tag wenn
sie das nicht hätten würden sie hungern
ihre väter sind ja oft hilfsarbeiter auf
baustellen und im hafen
aber nun haben wir eine krise sie haben
ihren job verloren und sind leicht
reizbar und nun sind die kinder den
ganzen tag zu hause und da kommt es eben
oft zu stresssituationen die sich leicht
in gewalt entladen können
an den straßen betteln ihre väter um
arbeit in der stadt stehen viele mit
ihren müttern um essen an
der knallharte lockdown hat die
wirtschaft erdrosselt es ist die
schwerste krise seit der staatsgründung
und die maßnahmen haben kaum etwas
gebracht die korona zahlen sind die
zweithöchsten in südostasien
alle trifft der lock down in den
besseren wohnlagen von manila sind die
straßen seit monaten die ausgestorben da
sitzt matthew seit über 4 120 tagen im
haus seiner großeltern vor dem computer
acht bis neun stunden jeden tag lernen
spielen zeit totschlagen
es ist als würde man unter einem großen
felsen leben auch wenn ich mit der
schule fertig bin und wenn ich dann mit
den kumpels online gespielt habe drückt
es mich immer wieder nach unten
seine freunde trifft er nur noch im
videochat wir dürfen ihn nicht
rauslassen sagen die großeltern zu
seiner sicherheit und zu unserer eigenen
der 13 jährige allein mit oma und opa in
einer doppelt schwierigen zeit
er ist jetzt an der schwelle zum
erwachsenwerden seine stimme wird
deutlich tiefer unglücklicherweise
kommen wir auf den philippinen mit dem
impfen nicht richtig voran
was ich so höre und lese könnte der
notstand noch zwei oder drei jahre
andauern
ganz unten in hitze dreck und müll
gestank im slum von happyland haben sie
gelernt auch mit den finstersten
aussichten zu leben und nicht aufzugeben
die menschen hier sind einfach sehr hart
im nehmen
trotz all der probleme sieht man sie
immer noch lächeln
ich sehe viele neue chancen ich sehe uns
nicht in fesseln die kleine mia hat es
wieder mal an der mutter vorbei auf die
gasse geschafft um mit ihren freunden zu
toben und kind zu sein auch wenn das
verboten ist
und sollte eine patrouille kommen haben
die kinder eine lösung
einmal hätten sie uns fast draußen
erwischt da sind wir einfach in ein haus
und haben so getan als würden wieder
wohnen und gerade einen mittagsschlaf
gemacht da ist uns nichts passiert wer
aufwächst zwischen der schnellstraße und
dem containerhafen am rande von manila
für den ist der lockdown eine qual und
corona ein schrecken
nur halt einer von vielen
[Musik]